good morning millennials to everyone
except claudia oh my god
jackie woke up on the wrong side of the
bed because theo wanted to sit with me
today instead of her that's not what
happened you guys all saw
literally as we were counting down
theo's here like he's lost his courage
about jumping up so i was tapping him to
get him up
you know trying to instill some
confidence in him and claudia just like
summoned him
over there just ripped him right out
from under me when
i haven't sat with him all week and he
matches my outfit
the thing is is that theo sits where he
wants to sit and like me tapping would
not have
if he wanted to sit with you tapping
would have done nothing i feel like i've
actually done that before
i i let my son choose his own destiny
and his destiny included sitting next to
me today
and i'm certainly not going to hinder on
that you being his mom like he went to
go play over here and then mom was like
come back here and he's a good son and
he obeys orders so he doesn't ran back
and he didn't he didn't hang with the
aunties and i just
it was her fault happy friday everyone
friday
friday we've been waiting four days for
one it's today
enjoy it relish savor it
yes happy friday last day of waking up
early today was a rough one
waking up and because it's a little bit
like moody here in new york i was just
like
you know the feeling of like being
snuggled under your covers yeah you know
i went to bed in new york city but i
woke up in moody's point
and that's crazy also like as someone
who suffers from rls like the morning is
when i'm
in the least amount of pain so i was
just like i heard um
that you had an enormous amount of
outreach from the rls community i had an
enormous amount of outreach and
then i also had outreach about the
outreach people being like
what were the suggestions like i have
rls too and so
i got a lot of people telling me to take
magnesium supplements i had a lot of
people telling me to take iron
supplements so then i said i was gonna
do those things and then i got a lot of
people telling me that iron makes you
constipated watch out your body doesn't
produce it naturally so i'm like okay
never mind not taking those but you
don't actually eat a lot of meat i feel
like you actually could benefit
from taking iron i feel like you bruised
like a peach yeah and i could also
benefit from eating
more meat so i'm just gonna keep that in
mind but i don't think i'm gonna take
the iron
i think the magnesium should help and
then also they said
that crossing your legs is harmful for
the rls
yet here you are so i need to be like
uncrossing my legs but like i don't know
how to sit on this show
cross your ankles no but like that's
nice crush your ankles
that's what i do sometimes i don't like
sitting with my legs crossed but you
literally just can't like spread your
vagina all over the couch
that's not that bad so i cross my ankles
it's very alien that's what the queen
does she doesn't even cross her she
doesn't even cross her legs
yeah i cross my legs so tight sometimes
they like wrap around each other i know
but i have to like
have to a given thing because i could
barely get one leg over the other
gotta give him a break okay i'm gonna
try the ankles we have a fabulous show
for you guys today
you know it's a big friday in the pop
culture industry
tons of new music um i just would be
remiss
devastated and even heartbroken if i
didn't mention the new
luke combs deluxe album songs so his
album which came out
um a year ago yeah in november wow that
i killed that was a year ago
um was fabulous and now we got his
deluxe version with five new songs one
of which we have already heard and one
of which
is forever after all which he released
the bridge of on tick tock a few months
ago which was such a brilliant marketing
move people have used it like for all
their like wedding videos
and now we have the full song and
sometimes when an artist releases the
song on tick
tock you can't help you've hyped it up
so much you cannot be disappointed seven
summers got leaked
on tick tock morgan wallin seven summers
and like people were furious that it
wasn't as good even though i think it's
great
um and this song just like lived up to
the hype and then some it's so beautiful
it's like the perfect country song it's
the perfect love song
the all the songs on luke's new um it's
so funny like i don't really relate to
any of luke holmes's music like my
favorite song
besides forever after all the new songs
that he released is called um
blue collar boys no well so that's what
i was going to say
the new song is um my kind of folk it's
all about people who go to church and
then wake up on monday go go back to
work then they fish on the weekends
and it's like can't relate to anything
on this level like don't go to church
don't fish i've never seen a deer in my
life
but i'm like my kind of folk like yeah
and that's how i feel his other song
blue collar boys there's guys
like a blue collar bowl and i'm not a
blue collar boy
but you're a white collar literally
criminal
um no i really am not a blue collar boy
and i am [ __ ] obsessed and i'm saying
that song
blue color boy like that's what luke
comes out to you and i think that's what
a good artist does
transcends you know
societal boundaries thank you thank you
you're welcome
and then we also have new music from
ariana grande which we have one person
in our comments who is rdh if they don't
let us know that we have to talk about
it for the last two days we like haven't
mentioned it because like i don't know
ariana grande releasing a new song like
i don't know if that's newsworthy no
here's the thing we actually did
make it a story last week when she
tweeted new music was coming and we're
like our ag6 and it started like this
whole conversation about selena
that she said she had new gomez coming
but the new music hadn't come yet what
do you want us to talk about
yeah the song dropped today it's called
positions and claudia and i have some
differing opinions i was just watching
the music video and i thought it was
so cute cute and claude is just not
impressed no it's not that i'm not
impressed but to me ariana grande is
unequivocally maybe tied with like adele
and beyonce like the greatest vocalist
of our generation
and i'm just constantly like and the
music she puts out is
not bad by any means but it's good for
someone like like a bb
rexa do you know what i mean i know
she's always my example and i [ __ ]
love bb rexa and i don't know why i keep
like putting her down
but i know i just i really expect a lot
from ariana grande and
i feel as though her old music used to
deliver way more than her current music
does like one last time
break free vodka soda you know like
th those songs were so um
powerful and i feel like really
highlighted her vocals and now she's
like in this
whispery tone and it's like it's just
it's good it's not bad music by any
means
i'm just like i have very high standards
for her and currently i'm not impressed
okay i think that's a fair assessment
though um i liked the song i thought the
video was
so cute her looks were so on point and i
love to see a little glamour
yeah no i like i love people who um
like invest in their music videos and
don't just do music videos because like
that's what
celebrity pop stars do yeah music videos
are important
to ari and they have like the past few
have been really
really good so of course she has set the
bar high for her own
music videos but i just like missed the
time like imagine if she put seven rings
out now and like it would fall
so flat yeah because it's literally like
all about material items like i just
miss like the world that we used to live
in the materialistic world
the material of super always like
whoever said money can't solve your
problem no totally
yeah um yeah i bet it's hard to like
release music
in this day and age like what do people
want no i know but that's why like we're
getting this vibe now i feel like justin
bieber's new song hits the nail on the
head lonely
oh literally the past three nights into
bed ben is literally
it's so annoying he like just learned
the song and he can't get it out of his
head
and he's like literally looking at me
and he's like are you okay
that is so funny it's so annoying and
then he's like
he never heard you laugh like that
and i'm like ben like he like ben
doesn't really keep up with music you
know so i'm like when he knows
a song that just came out it's shocking
to me and he's like i'm so
low and i'm like how do you know that
song it's just
it's he doesn't keep up with yeah i
don't even know that was a song you
could like
sing along with oh ask ben you
definitely can i will when i see him
tonight
also i made a a statement a few days ago
on the toast that i want to start
implementing in my life which is
watching jeopardy okay
and of course forgotten to watch
jeopardy every single day since then
because it's like at seven o'clock and
it's seven o'clock i'm in a transitional
period like
from day bed to night bed and it's just
i'm busy and i've realized now three
days in a row i forgot to watch jeopardy
but um some of the collections are on
netflix and it's like a collection of
winners
um so i'm watching this guy's streak
right now his name is john hill he is
the cutest like geekiest like dad ever
i'm obsessed with him and i watched
three episodes of jeopardy last night
and i'm telling you i don't know if it
was just
i i wanted to watch jeopardy because i
feel like i am dumb like i don't know a
lot about
history or just like trivia or math or
literature
i just i wasn't good in school and i
never like kept up with my
trivia and i put on these three episodes
and i don't know if maybe i was like
just watching three episodes that were
literally geared towards me but like
ben like my husband like thinks that i'm
the smartest woman alive i must have
gotten
over three episodes like 15 to 20
answers it was crazy
and some of them i was just guessing out
of my ass they were like showed a
picture of this building in l.a built by
world renowned
architect and i literally know one
architect so like frank lloyd wright
and it was frank lloyd wright oh yeah
you told us about frank lloyd wright
well but you know what you should do but
then even there was one about the
charlotte bronte there was a whole
category and i was like jane eyre
because that's
literally the only charlotte bronte
novel i know jane eyre so ben thinks i'm
like so smart i just gotta keep the ruse
alive you know what you should do
just to mess with him you should record
an episode of jeopardy watch it get the
answers and then like when it's jeopardy
time like play yesterday's episode
and have every single answer that's a
great idea
really freak out and record it for
patreon
that's a great idea yeah okay i like
that idea no i just honestly i think
that more people
more young people should be watching
jeopardy okay and
um i realize that alex trebek has the
best job in the world like
he literally sits there and does nothing
and
i don't even think he's reading the
clues i think they're pre-recorded
because it has a lot of like foreign
words that like he
probably has to like practice
pronouncing and i i think he pre-records
the
the hints interesting okay maybe i'll
check it out sometime but as you know my
content plate is
full last night um i was reading mariah
carey's
novel it is a certified novel definitely
and i just got to part two which is
called i think sing-sing so i think it's
about like
the first part was clearly about her um
childhood and now i think we're getting
into
her teenage years where she starts to
rise to stardom so
i was like this is a good place to set
it down for now and hopefully i have a
chance to finish it
this weekend but it is just so good
it is so good it is it is so good so
good
so good i got you
um so so without further ado is that
what you're going to say
yeah because we have the fast five we
have a little kardashian recap i have
kelly's mindless news to share
yeah we've got some [ __ ] to talk about
so i think without further ado it is
time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and while that may be true i would be
remiss devastated and heartbroken yes a
case of the rdh
if i didn't let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by our
patreon channel
what is patreon you ask well the morning
toast is here monday through friday for
free
but if you're ever looking for more
content can't get enough of your two
favorite gals
head over to patreon.com the morning
toast it is our premier subscription
service
you can pay 7.99 to get five extra
episodes every month from jackie and i
those episodes are podcasts their vlogs
videos anything more behind the scenes
family members olivia ben
literally anyone you want um it's
fabulous it's a fabulous way to get more
content and to support your favorite
show patreon.com morning toast once you
sign up
you get access to all the episodes we've
ever done which now is like
two years i think it's like over 200
episodes so it's a fabulous
7.99 so check it out patreon.com
the morning toast sign on get premium
content and for existing patrons we
just um posted a patreon episode
yesterday where we did what's in our
bags and
claudia and i showed you like us weekly
style what we have in our bags
yeah it's pretty shocking it's pretty
personal yeah
tampons um okay first story
tyra banks is slamming reports that she
doesn't want real housewives on dancing
with the stars
this okay i saw her the initial report
saying that she said that
saying that she said that she's the host
of dancing with the stars now
and apparently someone said that she
said that she doesn't want housewives on
the show and i just have to say let's
say tiger banks does feel this way
she's a host she's not a casting
producer i don't really think tara banks
has
any say in who gets cast on the show
yeah i would agree with that but it's
also
not true her longtime publicist said
this is 100 untrue
she's a huge fan of the housewives and
everyone knows tyra is a businesswoman
first
as a businesswoman why would she say
anything against the housewives she has
nothing to do with casting
we're told that tyra even tried to just
get one of her really good friends on
the housewives
she watches the shows she loves them
she's also familiar with
cynthia bailey from modeling and eva
marcel because she got her start on
america's next top model oh that's so
interesting so i feel
firmly that those reports were untrue
and like
make no sense yeah but it is an
interesting
jumping off point for tyra in the
dancing with the stars universe um
because this is her first season hosting
we're about halfway through the season
and
i only watched her first few episodes of
dancing with the stars and she seemed to
have like a tough time finding her
her footing um and i of course read
people on social media and people on
social media are just like automatically
negative like nobody's tweeting if they
think tyra is doing a great job like
they only tweet if they have something
bad to say but i am curious to
see where it takes her like is she gonna
do another season would they ever bring
back tom and aaron like
it was like a a transition for them and
i'm seeing
an overwhelming amount of people who are
unhappy with it which is shocking
because i love tyra but i did see her
stumble you know
a few times interesting i feel confident
that she'll find her footing and that
they will not bring back tom and erin
and it will
it will work itself out i hope they
don't bring back tom and erin i really
don't like
even though i was sad to see them go to
bring them back would just be stupid
yeah have you been watching dancing with
the stars no um
i i watched until carol baskin got
eliminated i think because i just
that's what i needed to see like for my
own soul um
but i've had a hard time keeping up
because you know what it's the same as
the bachelor
two hours once a week and then between
that and the bachelor like
i need self-care yeah no i hear you
and they do a really good job of like
not spoiling like i still don't know
who's been eliminated because all of the
stories about it's like
guess who's been eliminated but they
don't say it in the title and i don't
care enough to click so like i have no
idea how it's going that's what they do
with the masked singer too except that i
know that christelle is still on because
every week there's like a new story
about who she's dancing for
yeah in people magazine yeah um yeah no
i
agree with that they do that with the
math singer too like when they make
reveals
they i actually don't know one person
who's ever been on
the mask singer because i've never
watched it um but there are a lot of
claims there's a video going viral on
tick tock people think they figured out
it's tori kelly and that's
totally her how could it be tori kelly
she's literally
a singer is like i don't know the mass
singer is singers no but i feel like
it's also like people that you don't
expect to sound the way that they're
sounding i think it's both
but like it's meant to be people like i
could tell you tori kelly's voice that's
why i don't think it's her it's her
voice is too recognizable that wouldn't
be like
and leanne rhymes people are guessing
because
she's saying a song a lizzo song i'm
crying because i love you
and there's a video of her like in the
past on her tour bus like performing
that song with like her band
and it sounds very similar i actually
think she would sound so good on that
yeah leanne rhymes you know all the
drama with brandon glanville aside is
actually a very talented songwriter i
mean this is vocalist
yeah sure she's a talented songwriter
too she is interesting
i can't get into the math singer but i'm
sure i would like it if i did
hypothetically i would like to get into
it because i
the idea of like hearing someone sing
and then being able to place a name like
a face to the voice
is thrilling for me but the fact that
every episode it's like i watch the
first episode and i still don't know who
anyone is they don't reveal it it's
too much i need instant gratification
like it's too much waiting i'm not that
patient
yeah you should just binge watch old
seasons maybe
but it's still like hours and hours just
to find out it's cody simpson you know
right or it's jordan's uh jordan woods
um okay next story some scream queen's
crew news not about the reboot which is
apparently happening but emma roberts
says it's
witchcraft that liam michelle and billy
lord and i
are all boy moms oh and also i didn't
realize that they all had like gotten
pregnant and had babies at the same time
boys cute emma roberts joked that it's
pure witchcraft that she will join her
former scream queen's co-stars billy
lord and liam michelle
when she welcomes her baby boy i don't
know how else to explain it it was not
planned she recently uh
said on a serious xm show she's
expecting a son with her boyfriend
garrett
hedlund from claudia's favorite movie
two favorite movies
george rural and country strong yes oh
my god i think i'm just now realizing
is garrett hudlun my favorite actor he
might be he's in my two favorite movies
i know i just feel like he really should
have been on yellowstone
did you ever actually agree no i could
not get into it he reminds me
casey dutton's character like literal
physical character is that the brother
who was living on the reservation
yes reminds me just so much of garrett
and i just feel like he could have been
up for that part
or like taylor kitsch 100
yeah 100 um but back to the scream
queen's
mamas yes you know an exciting time to
be a scream queen and a screaming fan
this reminds me of how like the
vanderpump rules girls are like now all
pregnant at the same time together even
though
i heard them on a podcast day like it
was somewhat intentional like they did
want to do it together at the same time
um but this is like so much fun i feel
like motherhood
especially like your first baby like can
be intimidating like to have like all
your friends be going through it at the
same time
that must be really nice yeah and i
really i feel as though
friend groups often i don't think people
realize that they do this but like
people keep in mind like i want to be
pregnant around the same time that my
friends are being pregnant like i want
our kids to you know i don't want to be
the first one years ahead of the rest of
my friends like
so i think this is kind of like a
natural thing that some women do
is what i'm learning yeah i think so too
very cool very cool
and cool for the kids cool for the kids
and then that makes sense why like
when you were growing up you had so many
like family friends which was basically
and the kids are at the same age right
because it's basically just like our
parents were friends and then got
pregnant like at similar times
yes it all makes sense now
okay honestly growing up is pretty much
like understanding things that like your
parents did and like realizing like
everyone was probably drunk
you know like at all the dinners like
that's gonna be me yeah that will be you
i'm i'm literally gonna need a nanny for
the children and a nanny for me as well
i just don't know how i can drink as a
parent like with my hangovers it's not
about the drinking it's about like the
next two days being down and out but i
think when you go through childbirth
you become like a different person
medically do you know what i mean
like your body is so resilient that like
a hangover is nothing i shoved a kid out
of my [ __ ] you know
wow you know what i really hope that's
true and it actually like
scientifically makes it make sense 100
i'm not making this up yeah
no it's once you shove a kid at a regime
you can handle a hangover you can
literally like get a headache and it's
nothing and you just have like more
bandwidth physically emotionally
mentally for
[ __ ] yeah yeah interesting okay
cool that's your daily medical segment
from dr faceman
doctor and i was actually sitting this
morning thinking about like dr ficheiman
himself
and i was just laughing so hard as about
how like he's like dr
theo pacheman based off of doctor leo sp
german from 30 right from 30 rock and it
just like cracks me up when i
needs pachemin because he's such a face
man no we used to come hi cute face
man yeah man with her face um also you
know what i was doing this morning
sitting and laughing
um so somebody started a thread in the
toast after dark which is our only
existing facebook group and it's for
patreon members only it's a fabulous
place
i'm asking like when you first started
listening to the toast like what were
your biggest misconceptions about it
so a lot of people obviously didn't
realize that me and jackie were sisters
a lot of people thought you and margo
were sisters and then me and olivia were
sisters and maybe we were cousins yes
um just seeing what people thought was
so funny a lot of people thought that
olivia owned
the live method yeah the gym which like
makes a lot of sense makes
so much sense is so funny a lot of
people what were the other ones
um a lot of people thought that you're
older than me oh of course
of course and a lot of people thought
that
theo is a human son yeah claudius
people who listen to the podcast don't
watch on youtube for like the first
couple months were just like assuming i
had a son
like a human son yeah so that's not a
misconception they learned that theo
technically
is a furry little friend oh my god i
literally dreamt of him as he was lying
next to me like
that's claudia that's beautiful it was
to like
you know like you dream about something
and like sometimes it's a really good
dream you almost want to go back in the
dream
but like imagine waking up in in the
presence of your dream
that's like stunning yeah it's pretty
meaningful
try not to be jealous i mean
you know where i stand i know like i'm
putting on a good face i know i know
that you hurt me i know i know
i know i'm kidding but look how happy he
looks like i don't know if he was
yeah no he's had peace and that's what i
want for him and if he was laying with
you like i just don't know if he would
be that happy at the end
everyone heard that right because i'm
trying to remain positive and like
and just do what's best for theo and
you're throwing
daggers no sorry i don't know i should
have mentioned this i'm a comedian i
make jokes
wow hurtful ones hurtful painful ones
curly ones another one another quote
directly from my comedy special
disgraced queen which i haven't promoted
in a while
available on multiple streaming services
you can buy it on amazon prime you can
buy it on
itunes you could buy it on youtube you
could buy it on apple tv
tons of places you could also rent it on
all those places check it out it's a
fabulous product and one i'm really
proud of and if you're looking for
something to watch this weekend because
we can't do anything
disgraced queen claudia you it's
available as an audio comedy album if
you like to listen to podcasts it's
available on spotify amazon music apple
music you can also get it there it's the
ultimate content upper oh [ __ ] i should
have put in our lives a little
self-promo i'll do a sequel to this
oh because i had an addition to the list
what because i said so with diane keaton
and
mandy moore literally the best movie
ever okay and also i would like
and this would be a great segue into our
next story the hannah montana movie okay
it's a content upper for me because
that's where i first heard the climb and
it changed my life
yeah our next story miley cyrus
announces her seventh album plastic
hearts
she says i found myself you guys this is
like our theory
just like being proven our hypothesis um
which is like every new miley album like
she's finally she's finally the real
miley no it's like no no guys
this is it she is finally coming miley
cyrus will release her seventh studio
album plastic hearts on november 27th
the pop star announced on instagram
thursday night the new album will
feature 12 original tracks including her
latest hit midnight sky
as well as live covers of heart of glass
by blondie and zombie by the cranberries
i can't see the cranberries without
saying my cranberry cd
i think i left it in the quad oh my
that's funny i gotta go before somebody
snags it
really quickly of all the like most
recent miley cyrus albums which one did
you think was really going to be like
this is it like this is the truth this
is the true miley
um well i think oh there are so many
i i i want to say younger now but i felt
like that was like kind of like granny
miley
i thought it was gonna be um she is
coming that one mother's daughter
yeah but then i guess it wasn't no not
at all but and i don't i'm cautiously
optimistic
i actually think this might be like this
rocker vibe she's going for like this
joan jet
mullet heart of glass i was born run
i don't believe it's a really [ __ ]
good song oh no it's really good
i think she might be getting closer to
the real miley and i think that's what
it is like all these albums are like a
step
towards well i think that is you know
a metaphor for life where you know every
you're always evolving and changing and
today is
you are the yours you that you've ever
been but like
to negate all of her previous work by
saying like this is finally me
right i don't think it needs to be like
that i agree you know um
and then like think back to malibu when
it's like finally we're seeing like
miley stripped down this is who she is
like
and now i just feel like she's always
like
negating yeah her old work no it's like
once the press and the promo
and the you know the album has moved off
the charts like she's on to another one
yeah even like can't be tamed at that
point like that was the real miley she
couldn't be tamed and like
i really did feel like at that time that
was the real miley cyrus that was the
real mind i know what she should do
because that album is [ __ ]
fire if she should make a can't be tamed
like 2.0
and re-record it with like her new sound
and you know all of her new
vocal skills it would be unstoppable is
it love
or is it art cause the way you got your
body moving it's got me confused and i
can't tell if it's the beat or spider
so many good songs she recently covered
her own song that song
at an i heart musical festival and it
was amazing
every rose has its thorn
every rose every rose i know that's
actually not her song it's brett
michaels but yeah
i have to say i do think this will
actually be gonna be probably the most
successful miley album in the last three
or four for one reason and that's
because
she very organically has
taken over tick tock her heart of glass
the only reason she released
heart of glass as an official single is
because her performance at the i heart
radio
went so viral on tick tock that she
capitalized on it
now her capitalize should now her cover
of
why you only ever call me when you're
high
also went viral on tick tock she's like
engaging with the content
and tick tock is known to make or break
music and i think that tic toc is on her
side so i like i said i'm very
cautiously optimistic about this album
and i will be listening and you know
i've been
very hard on miley like very hard
artistically i just want the best for
her and
honestly i don't think i've seen the
best for miley since can't be tamed
album and a few songs on younger now but
pretty much can't be tamed and i've been
very hard on her but i think
i think we're getting close yeah i do as
it available but it isn't i guess it's
like a month no i know it's just
it's not as far away as legally blonde
three that's so
is that like our bar now yeah okay yeah
because that was insane
insane like don't announce something two
years in advance like i get anxiety when
like i have to announce something
because like
i think with my comedy special i left
too much time i announced five weeks
before and like by the fifth week i was
we were just exhausted i'm like
just [ __ ] watch it like it's the
timing and so to announce something
you really it's a quibby you know when
you announce yourself so early you kind
of set yourself up for failure
yeah there's definitely a sweet spot of
like excitement hype
but then enough time to get people to
prepare to purchase to show up like
but then also i've moved on exhaustion
yeah okay this next story is one of the
funnier headlines i've seen
dave portnoy denies hanging out with
ramona singer
this is the most strange 2020
headline i've ever seen in my life the
barstool sports honcho also known as el
presidente recently denied rumors that
he and the real housewives of new york
star ramona singer
previously hung out together in the
hamptons he responded via
instagram
shut the [ __ ] up
i hope everyone's okay please
go away drive away
i'm gonna sing till the sound of the
siren is gone
yeah okay can you start again please
yes the bar sewell sports honcho also
known as el presidente recently denied
rumors that he and the real house size
of new york star ramona singer
previously hung out together in the
hamptons he responded being
via an instagram message saying who the
[ __ ] is ramona singer
in the original claim which was posted
to du moy's instagram story
yesterday with the press ramona singer
was said to be at a hamptons
some time ago and portnoy was in
attendance as well
portnoy then doubled down in his
instagram message saying um no i did not
hang out with her
oh my god that's so funny i mean i feel
like they don't run in similar circles
but they definitely hang out at maybe
similar places like upscale
new york city brasseries and restaurants
and also
this summer in the hamptons perhaps yes
and they definitely have like walked
past each other i just feel like they've
been in the same room like
not more than one more than one time
yeah i would agree with that so
when i when i first saw the thing on
joomla like they were together at a
restaurant like ramona was like flirting
with this young guy i'm like
she might not have even known who he was
but like this is totally true
that's hysterical and i feel like it's
still very possible that they were like
at the same restaurant and dave porter
just like had no idea who this older
woman was
yeah no 100 i said i think they probably
eat
i think they have like the same taste in
restaurants i agree like elevated
upscale dining you know what's so funny
one time i saw dave portnoy at a
restaurant me too
and it's it was over madison which is
like one of ramona's
favorite restaurants it's one of like
the upper east side ladies favorite
places to go so like
they definitely have the same taste in
cuisine i saw him at ilmolino which is
literally one block away which is also
like an upper east side
ladies luncheon type of place so i just
think that dave point
portnoy appreciates like an upper east
side luncheon yeah and
i respect that i respect it as well i
just thought i was a hysterical headline
no it's so
like red two people whose names you
never thought would be in the same
sentence
yet here we are here we are in the same
sentence speaking of two people who are
coming back to the same sentence
chloe and tristan were showing some pda
at kim's 40th birthday party
now i know they have been previously
china'd but i
chose to unchina because i'm happy for
them
okay well i'm not on china in them
because i just i'm ex
i get exhausted keeping up with
relationships like this like if this was
your friend you wouldn't put up with it
so i'm not putting up with it
with it from chloe but i do want to talk
about kim's 40th birthday party and the
special they put on this week so
i'll let you discuss and then we can
dive into that the couple attended the
kkw beauty founders
surprise bash which was featured on
wednesday's episode of keeping up with
the kardashians
at the party tristan was spotted kissing
chloe on the cheek while they posed for
a picture in a photo booth
it's unclear when the episode was was
filmed yes very unclear would like to
dive into that
but the party took place sometime after
the duo reunited
so in my head of like their relationship
and like what i've made up in my own
fanfiction
i feel like they reunited during and due
to
quarantine well yeah i think that you
know
tristan did not make the nba playoff so
he's been like
out of the bubble for a little while and
in
lockdown you want to be with your family
yeah so i think
they were together for the quarantine
they think that you know maybe some
sparks were flying well he like seemed
to be like
fun and like had a good attitude in the
episode um
for all the kim birthday stuff so i
don't know i i don't dislike him i know
that i should
like because he like because he did what
he did twice
but i i'm giving him like another chance
i am because i believe in second and i
guess third
chances here and before me thrice
shame on me so i'm going to hold out i'm
not
shipping them by any means i just like
want true to be happy i want chloe to be
happy and like if this could work out
of course in an ideal world i would of
course want that to happen but it seems
like it may not be able to work out
yeah when i was watching the special
last night i'm like i was like it must
be really awkward for kylie and tristan
to be in the same room yes
you know yeah i don't think that she
could
acknowledge or like move on in the way
that everyone else has like kim and
tristan
it's so crazy she went from that was so
funny
yeah um let's talk about the birthday
special i liked
to be honest when i thought so they were
doing a 40th birthday special they were
all like sitting on
in those chairs outside in malibu like
reflecting on old episodes like
i wasn't gonna watch because i just
thought it was like silly but i didn't
realize it was like this whole element
with the birthday party
and it was really really sweet honestly
i got like a little emotional
because the kardashians have this
emphasis which i really really love and
appreciate
on just like memories and nostalgia
nostalgia and like ting walks down
memory lane and like the fact that like
so many of their big
milestones in life like include these
like home videos and like recreating the
diner like i just thought it was really
really sweet and like when kim got out
of the car and like she didn't know
what's going on then heard her dad's
voice like
that that's just like it's beautiful
yeah i agree
one of my favorite parts of the episode
having nothing to do with the emotions
though was like we finally got a little
clarity on that house with the staircase
that everyone's been posting out all
summer
the malibu vacation house and it was
absolutely
beautiful so i was and like the scenes
of them just like sitting and eating and
talking like i wasn't even listening to
what they were saying about like with
mindy and the planning like
i was just watching like it was
i just love watching them eat like yeah
food looked so good the setting looked
so
stunning they looked so beautiful i was
just like this is just enjoyable stuff
the episode also felt like a major
commercial for mindy weiss event
planning because she just did such a
good job and she got so much air time
like more so than usual
yeah well i'm sure like she did it for
free and she got that car even though it
seems like they paid for the party
because she was like i hope it's okay we
got the car because we already got it no
they definitely paid for it and then the
towel element was so fun like
kim kim's like iconic tau birthdays in
vegas are just like a part of americana
like they really are
yeah and they just like it's like they
don't they're not obsessed with
nostalgia like only from their childhood
like also from their 30s like yeah
it's so epic and that was just like such
a cool unique thing that only they could
really do like
get tau open for the night for sure also
when they were going down memory lane
and you see like kim cringing so hard at
like things that she used to do and then
you see like her now with kanye and it's
like
she actually summed this up really well
on dave letterman when she was like
we used to try so hard to like be famous
and now we just try so hard to show you
like we're just like you
no i thought that was a i agree a very
interesting distinction because that's
what the show was at first like photo
shoot this that like
oh i have to go to red carpet but mom
reggie bush's thing like
yes and now it's just like hey who's
gonna pick the kids up from school yeah
it's an interesting shift but i feel it
is also
organic that's why we like didn't
realize that it was happening until it
happened
watching the um highlights of her and
kanye just like
i was literally up staring at my tv
screen like
yeah it was so so so cute i just wish
kim would embrace her
jam era a little bit more like she's she
has so much shame associated with it and
it's such an iconic song and like it's
not that bad and her voice even when
she's in the booth
really wasn't so bad like i've seen
worse on reality tv
and i just need her to embrace it turn
me up turn me up
yeah i feel like a few years ago she
made peace with it
but she doesn't want to be watching it
no and i think that's why she doesn't
like going on watching happens live
because andy literally brings it up
at every corner every time she's been on
watch travis
i can't i like i can't when she's like i
literally can't look at this i can't
listen to this like i know that feeling
it's like when you watch
yourself being cringy and you're just
like in you know your own bedroom
yeah of course um the dress that she
wore to her birthday party was
absolutely sickening like i never saw a
dress
so stunning in my whole life that like
fit her so well yeah
no they did a great job with the
logistics of getting her to look her
best
so that she would be excited for her
party and when she when they pulled her
in
for the dance and she just like is so
awesome no she's awkward but so
cute and so beautiful like i literally
like was looking at him like
this is my queen like yeah i don't know
i yesterday
we talked about her on dave letterman i
didn't think i could like feel any more
like warmly towards her and then just
watching the special i was just like
even more endeared
i want to talk about the dance for a
minute because i'm very hard on kourtney
kardashian
what you're about to say is literally
what i'm about to say i'm very very hard
on her and to be honest like
she was the only sister who put in so
much effort i had a lot of respect for
her for like
i know it seems silly like it's a dance
like it was an important part of the
party and like she wouldn't let it go
and none of the sisters wanted to do it
and she ended up doing it alone and she
didn't waver
in her willingness to do it and she was
like trying to rally everyone and i just
had like i know it seems so silly but
like
i had a lot of respect for her in that
moment no i had a lot of respect for her
in the whole episode she was really
being like a big sister
yeah and like the courtney that is the
best sort of courtney they weren't
fighting about work or this or that or
push and you know yeah all this nonsense
they were just being siblings and she
was being the big sis and like
i felt warmly towards her as well i
think that
of all of them courtney probably has had
the most
success like emotionally and mentally
from lockdown like spending time with
her kids
not having to deal with like outside
factors they can't film they can't do
photo shoots
and you know that's the stuff that
doesn't make her happy and she just like
wants to be with her family and that's
what she's been doing for the last six
months and there was definitely like a
different
vibe to her she was like lighter and
funnier and she didn't seem like hostile
towards anyone
and it was a great courtney yeah a great
coordinator i picked up on that as well
it was a good special i liked it i'm
ready to go back to regular episodes
because like i need to see
chloe get the coronavirus but well not
that i want to but i just like want to
see what happened
yeah um so i'm ready to return to our
regularly scheduled programming
as am i but it was a nice little treat a
nice content upper
um before we wrap up today i have a
little news to share do you
would you say that it's mindless news it
is
or is it mindful no no it is definitely
a segment of
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july
now i will post the proof on our
instagram as you always do but in the
meantime
kelly ripa shares glimpse into unseen
living room in the hamptons with garden
view
so what do you think this means like you
as an average reader okay so
now that i'm getting keen to no no no
i'm saying it's a
it's a picture of kelly in her living
room where you could see bits of a
living room and like out a window
okay no no but i want you like don't
answer that way what would you you read
this article you weren't
of course i think it's like a carousel
spread architectural
digest style photos of a living room and
a garden view
well you're wrong kelly ripa has a
beautiful home in the hamptons where she
spends a lot of her weekends
and the live with kelly and rhinestar
recently shared a glimpse into one of
those
into inside one of the property's many
living rooms this spacious area has a
monochrome theme
features a cream sofa as well as a table
with gray chairs
and a black shelf filled with wine
glasses the room has beige curtains and
a large window overlooking the family's
large garden
okay so that's a decent amount of
descriptors table
chair couch drapes window
show me the kmn what the [ __ ] you're
lying
i swear it's a selfie you guys oh my god
you guys this is this is not even
and it's from an ig story it's not it's
not like a post photo it's not even what
i thought it was
i didn't know i could still shock you
with the case that was so [ __ ] crazy
i thought it was going to be a picture
like uh in feed of her sitting on her
couch
with her living room looking pretty
behind her like still not cause for a
news article but it's kmn it is what it
is you guys
this is crazy no it's so disgraceful on
behalf of hello magazine no no that is
so
crazy but kelly is um encouraging people
to register to vote which everyone
should do so if that's what we take away
from kelly's mindless news
it's not so much it's not so mindless
and that's all you can ask for for a
segment of kmn
a little mindfulness um that's our show
that's our week anything you want to say
before we depart for two days of alarm
free living
no i'm just so looking forward to
getting to that place i was like in my
bed this morning
snoozing my alarm and i was like this is
the last time we can do it and i was
like in there thinking like about
i was got into like a really delicious
position nothing better than when you're
like
because it's really like a crime
of the world order that like when you go
to sleep you can't get comfortable
but when you wake up and you have to get
up you've never been more comfortable
beds feel so much better at 8am than
they do at 8pm yeah no like
i don't know what the science is behind
that but
it's not there why can't it be delicious
when i get in
and then uncomfortable when i have to
get out right it ain't right i was just
like
no i know what you mean it's absolutely
devastating i'm actually dealing with
something in my bed right now
um if you wanted to know so me and ben
recently not recently but a few months
ago we got a new mattress tempur-pedic
highly recommend
and we've been loving it but it's i
would say it's a bigger mattress
height wise than our previous mattress
and our brooklyn sheets we wake up every
morning
the sheets are curled up off the corners
like in a ball at the bottom
and we're like laying on the mattress
which honestly the mattress is so soft
and comfortable i don't mind but it is a
little annoying
so a week ago i ordered um
these little gadgets they're like
suspenders you put on the corner
whatever it's like this whole thing and
it worked and i like returned to this
peaceful place
in my bed and this week for the first
time in a while i had my housekeeper
come
and i don't know where she put the
little suspenders and like i had peace
for a week and now i can't find the
spenders and i woke up this morning
where's the sheet in a ball on the floor
that is so crazy very aggressively but
it has smiled
but we also have the sheet problem like
i think any human would have the sheet
problem but it might not end up on the
floor
yeah do you guys use a top sheet also
[ __ ] no what do you think we're
sociopaths that might help why
because sometimes your top sheet like
takes the brunt of the kicking and the
but don't you lay underneath the top you
do but like
it might just disorient your top sheet
and you should just try it no honestly
because i'm the one making the bed and
i'm not dealing with a flat sheet it's
it's honestly
a terrorist organization like it's it's
terrorizing
i don't know i think like part of
growing up is realizing the value of the
flat sheet and why you even have one
i used to like when i was um younger
like five years ago i used to like
use the top sheet as like i will sleep
on top of my top sheet and then in two
weeks i will take my top sheet off and
then i'll sleep on my just regular sheet
that way i don't have to change my
sheets
very smart isn't that pretty smart but
now i go the full monty and
you have a top sheet yeah and i'm just
like so you sleep on the top sheet
underneath the top sheet and underneath
your comforter yes
on top of the stretchy sheet yes
very interesting and sometimes if you're
feeling a little warm you take off your
comforter and then you're just with your
top sheet like very
top sheets are very sexy to me that is
the only value of a top sheet when you
get hot
to just sleep with it alone and that's
what i do like in hotels if i get hot
got it just something to consider no i'm
i'm definitely considering it
but it's so much added work for like
laundry and but i
feel as though like the two hardest
parts of bed
making first duvet cover 100 second
getting the corners of your corner
sheets
on the bed while not coming off of the
other tires
the top sheet is a walk in the park no
let me ask you do you tuck your top
sheet in
all around i stuff it away so it's not
hanging out the bottom no but i mean
when you're sleeping
do you pull it out of the tuck oh it's
out of here it's out of tuck yeah ben
would
kill me like i know he he like relates
so hard to that episode of seinfeld
where like george costanza is in the
hotel and they like
tuck the sheets in too tight he gets
like stuck in the bed and it's true like
honestly when sheets are so heavily
tucked that you like get a cramp try to
kick it out yeah
then then it's like my bed has become a
negative place and i can
i just can't have that well first of all
i just want to say like my top sheet is
always
loosey-goosey so that's not an issue and
it sounds like your bed is
already giving you some negativity so no
no no no it's not
it's not even though you just said no i
i i have a fix i just need to find my
suspenders
and i don't know how to text my
housekeeper and be like where are the
suspenders
i just can't imagine that the suspenders
are easier to operate than the top sheet
no you put them on once and
literally i they were on for a week
before i had to change my sheets
no i forgot they were even on and i woke
up every day and my cheat was i was
still on my sheet which was
crazy does anyone else have this problem
i like googled did i thought it was like
a very common thing and i only found
like some weird like sleep apnea blog
which recommended these amazon things
for me and they worked but it doesn't
it seems like this is either an untapped
market or nobody has this problem except
for me no because i that
i've never heard of it but i don't want
to you know say thanks and i don't want
to make you
feel like you know like it's me like so
maybe it sounds like it's something that
could be a thing but it also sounds like
the two of you maybe you both have
extreme rls
maybe and your legs are just so restless
it's possible they're taking off the
sheets or maybe it's theo sabotaging you
he would never he might all right you
guys
that's our show now that's our show have
an amazing weekend
be nice to your friends sorry i sound
like ellen oh my god but still really be
nice to your friends wear a face mask
don't drink and drive i just heard a
vote
fine um well vote at this point but true
find moments of inner peace for yourself
take some time for yourself that's the
best advice you could have given our
audience
don't forget to find inner peace yeah
even if it's just a few minutes of inner
peace for the whole weekend right
good the thing about inner peace is that
it's constantly fleeting so when you
have it
just savor it savor thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box we're now available
on amazon music
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast
and leave a five star review please
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are because we just read our reviews
and they're really [ __ ] mean
you guys they're so crazy and terrible
but you know what i think that's like
what the reviews are for like i've
written them off
i actually think that soon apple will
get rid of um
reviews like written reviews because
they have become such a talk
like they're a place for like trolls who
live in their basements like yeah
that's where they exist it's like you
yelp you know you only write a review
and you have something negative to say i
don't know how that's productive
so we'd appreciate any positive reviews
i really would maybe talk about like how
beautiful we are
stunning or smart have an amazing
weekend we will see you guys on monday
we got a big week next week don't forget
two big announcements from jackie
and i and i just want you to gear up get
yourselves mentally ready
yeah it's gonna be fun and then it's
halloween show on friday so it's just
gonna be a super fun week
to round out the month and we're just
gonna soak up each other's awesomeness
oh yeah
have a great weekend guys we'll see you
on monday goodbye
you